(upbeat music)
(laughing)
- It's a joke. Right?
(sighing)
- I have it good but--
- It takes forever!
- I would rather be locked up in a cage
with anacondas for an hour.
- I'm worried that I might not
remember the capital letters.
- Capital letters.
- Aren't you supposed to do it all in one?
I'm not doing that.
- Yeah.
- Yeah. Sure.
Give it a whirl.
(drum roll)
- [Speaker] Hello.
- The H should be the easiest.
- I don't know the letters of cursive.
Now I'm just making like bubble letters.
- This is probably a level one.
It was pretty easy.
- This looks like the illuminati!
- I think it looks weird.
- Bye.
(drum roll)
- [Kids] Foxes!
- Okay.
Ah!
(exhaling)
- I love foxes.
Give me motivation.
- This already looks pretty bad.
- Is it like that?
- I'm just gonna try to make fancy print.
- The X'll --
Oo. That looks gorgeous.
- Okay. Here's my results!
(laughing)
- It's like a little.
It's like someone saying,
"Stop making me do cursive"!
(drum roll)
- [Speaker 2] I love pizza.
Well. It's totally the opposite but --
Yeah. I can make it a sentence.
- Is that an I?
(laughing)
- Pretty!
- Okay.
That one was definitely bad.
- Here's my results!
(laughing)
I, supposed to be capital.
And I should probably add a sad face.
(laughing)
- 'Cause --
- No. I think it's a
waste of time in school.
- When you're writing a
letter to the president
or someone like that.
They probably would prefer cursive.
So I think it's really
important for you teachers
to teach your kids how to do cursive.
- I'm so gonna just use
my normal handwriting.
I don't want to use cursive
in the future ever again.
- It's creepy.
Okay cursive.
No!
This is horrible.